Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am
going to explain a Sci-Fi drama film
called “Welcome to Earth.” Spoilers
ahead! Watch out and take care!
The premise of the movie is set in the year 2618
when the human species has gone extinct
and the earth is not what it used to be.
The climate conditions are so extreme that a
powerful sand storm covers every part of the
earth throughout the year. A spaceship lands
on the surface amidst the sand storm. Four
extraterrestrial species step out of the ship
and make their way through the powerful wind.
They stop in front of an entrance to a building.
The alien who is leading the group opens the door
easily. It is almost as if they have been here
before and are revisiting the earth for a purpose.
Following that, they get on an elevator that
takes them somewhere under the ground. The
building seems to be a bunker that was constructed
to hold life after the conditions on the surface
got too harsh for the humans to survive. When the
elevator stops, they come across a hallway.
The doors open by themselves, inviting them in. On
walking inside, they hear a loud noise from behind
them and are startled. This notifies the automated
computer system that the aliens can in fact hear.
It announces the sense of hearing has been
detected. Following that, a bright light
flashes onto their faces making them turn away.
The automated voice again claims that visual
senses have been detected. It is still unclear to
the aliens what they are dealing with. The voice
then asks them if they encountered a satellite
that led them the way. If yes, one of them must be
accustomed to earthly visual concepts. Following
the announcement, three of the tall aliens take
their masks off, revealing their blue complexion
and eyes that only have pupils. The leader, on the
other hand, still stays hidden behind the mask. To
test the magnitude of their knowledge of earthly
concepts, the automated voice asks them to select
one of the pictures displayed on the monitor,
in accordance with the given word. The leader
steps forward to take on the task. The first
word he is given is “horse”. Among four pictures
of random animals, he chooses a horse. Next, he
is asked to choose a tree among the pictures of a
flower, a plant, and a mushroom. He chooses a tree
correctly, proving that he is educated on earth’s
concepts. At last, he is asked to select the
picture of a satellite which he does perfectly.
After the brief test, the voice confirms the
knowledge and understanding of speech in
the species. Moments later, a video starts
to play on the monitor. A scientist in the video
explains that the place they are in is a museum
on human history that had been established in
2117. It was an effort to preserve knowledge
about humans when they had no hopes left
for survival. It is meant to showcase the
history of humanity and was built with the
help of the council of human preservation.
Only the leader seems to be understanding the
clip while the others wait for the explanation.
The scientist then claims that it is a human
tradition to greet one another and so, he welcomes
the aliens to the earth. He follows it by saying
that unfortunately, humans have gone extinct.
The last alien is about to take off his mask but
the comment makes him freeze. The professor in
the video explains that the museum contains ten
billion records and ten million samples of human
society. When the alien involuntarily asks how
the humans went extinct, the video stops playing.
The system recognizes the command and proceeds
to explain how the extinction of humans began.
It says that humans failed to understand the
true origin of the world but despite the fact,
they made significant progress in technology.
Clips of people landing on the moon,
building satellites, and doing revolutionary
things are shown. The aliens watch in awe, finally
understanding what the earth was like before the
climate change. However, soon, the clips change
from happy to destructive ones. Countries and
states fight for territories. The aliens realize
that humans took too much from nature to the
point that nature couldn’t save them anymore.
They were the cause of their own downfall. As
a last resort to save the world, the officials
decided to ask for help from extraterrestrial
creatures with whom they share the universe.
For this, they sent human ambassadors to different
parts of space to look for aliens and ask for
help. As the screen shows the pictures of the said
ambassadors, the leader touches the face of one
of them named Rene Shepard. The computer detects
the touch input and starts to explain the story of
the ambassador. Rene had joined the fleet in 2087
and was one of the seven ambassadors who were sent
to look for extraterrestrial creatures. He was
selected fourth in a class of four hundred people.
A flashback shows Rene attending a training
session the ambassadors had to take
before they were sent for the mission.
The Com Officer Whitney explains to them
about a black box called the knowledge probe
that is made especially for the mission.
The device contains everything that is necessary
to teach an alien about earthly language
and behavior. When the ambassadors finally meet
an alien species, they are supposed to use it
to teach them about the planet and convince
them to aid humans. Whitney also explains
that they have already sent six thousand
such devices to different parts of space.
The last seven boxes will be accompanied by
the ambassadors. Right before they are sent off
for the mission, Representative Alice tells them
that this might be the most important mission for
humankind and expresses gratitude towards all the
ambassadors who are willing to risk their lives
for the people. At the end of the convention,
they swear to find extraterrestrial help
or die trying to do so. The ambassadors, including
Rene, are let to meet their families for the last
time. His father asks him to send a postcard from
space to which he jokingly says that he will make
an alien bring it. His mother, on the other
hand, is worried for her son’s safety. She asks
him to pilot the space pod safely. He kisses his
wife and takes a picture with his family, hoping
that he will meet them again. The ambassador who
takes the picture is his best friend Tess.
The ambassadors then finally board the space pods
that each of them is supposed to pilot. Rene puts
his family’s picture on the control panel and gets
ready for the initiation of the mission. His wife
tells his parents she has a feeling all of this
is wrong but it is too late for Rene to turn
back. The pods finally take off and soon enter
hyperdrive. Rene experiences some heavy turbulence
because of the speed of the pod but it stops soon
when he reaches his first destination. He starts
the scans for the first waypoint to check if the
area is inhabited by any extraterrestrial beings.
Back in the control room, each ambassador
has their own com officers who report them on
what they have to do next. When Rene’s results
come back negative, he is told to jump further
into space to the second point. He drives through
space at a very high speed again. One of Rene’s
colleagues is in his fourth waypoint. When he
doesn’t find the evidence of living beings,
he tries to jump to the other part of space but
his pod explodes, killing him instantly. Now,
only six ambassadors are left. Back in the control
room, they try to check his vitals but receive no
signal. They realize that he is dead and cover his
part of the control panel with a white cloth.
Following that, Whitney announces to all
the officers that they have lost one of
their ambassadors which creates tension
among them. Yet, they remain professional
and carry on with the mission. In the meantime,
Ambassador Tess is in her eighteenth waypoint
going stronger than everyone else. However,
one after another the ambassadors begin to die
because of pod malfunctions, oxygen failures, and
getting way too close to a star. After a few days,
Tess, Rene, and an ambassador are the only ones
left. Tess asks the com officer how everyone is
doing to which she lies and says that they are
fine. Tess jokingly says that she will beat Rene
to the mission and continues the jump. However,
she gets too close to the sun during the jump
and dies. Back on earth, her control
panel is also covered in a white cloth.
It has been several days since the mission
started and Rene is in the waypoint 213.
He asks the com officer about Tess. To keep his
spirit up, the officer lies and says that Tess
is doing great. He also playfully comments that
he will beat her to the aliens and continues the
jump. After the comment, another ambassador
dies, making him the only surviving one.
On his way to waypoint 214, Rene’s pod starts to
malfunction. Everyone on earth who is hoping for
his survival is on their feet. The com officer
tries to retrieve data from the pod but fails.
Eventually, Rene loses all control of the pod
and it crashes on a blue planet that looks
awfully like the earth. Since the pod lands on
land with a thick layer of snow on top, Rene
has no fatal injuries. However, the temperature of
the planet is way lower than his body can handle.
His face turns blue with frostbites as he
looks at the picture of his family. In the end,
even the last ambassador is lost, leaving humanity
with no hopes for survival. The cause of death is
recorded to be rapid freezing because of a hostile
atmosphere. If coincidentally, the planet has an
intelligent species living on it, Rene’s preserved
body still has a ten percent chance of revival.
The representative Alice tells Whitney that
they cannot announce the deaths to the public
because then, the people will go into a frenzy.
Whitney, who is mourning his soldiers’ deaths,
harshly claims that the men who
died for humanity deserve respect.
However, Alice stays put in her decision. Although
the public was kept in the dark, they informed the
families of the ambassadors of their deaths.
A private funeral is held in honor of them. His
death marked the end of the alien outreach
program. No alien help was found as they had
predicted. Back in the bunker, the last alien
takes off his mask and reveals that he is
actually Rene; the only ambassador who completed
the mission successfully and brought alien aid
to the earth. But he is too late. We can predict
that he was revived by the blue-skinned aliens who
are the inhabitants of the snowy planet. The
computer announces that Rene’s files contain
more than ten thousand messages, eight hundred
pictures, and some video entries left by his
loved ones. He asks the computer to show all of
them. The movie ends as he watches a video of him
hugging his family before his departure.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thank You for watching.